so this um headline is a great  opportunity to talk about the thing I  most care about which is attention  Arbitrage  um as you there's been smoke around the  FCC uh and the U.S potentially Banning  Tick Tock like it was banned in India as  you can imagine as someone who's  focused on making sure his community and  clients get the best attention Arbitrage  meaning extracting attention for  whatever purposes they have their  business their hopes and dreams you know  people have been like what do you think  about this I think that  I only focus on where the attention of  the consumer is so I was winning on  MySpace and then it sold and wasn't  popular I was winning on Vine and then  it sold and it wasn't popular snap  YouTube Twitter Tumblr social cam was a  big platform for me if Tick Tock gets  banned all that attention goes somewhere  else and I'll be the first to move on it  and execute on it